this is expected to be the busiest
travel season in years this summer more
than 70 percent of americans say they
plan on taking at least one trip but as
prices soar for everything from gas to
airfares travelers are getting hit with
some serious sticker shock chris van
cleave is near an amusement park in
arlington texas chris is the price of
admission up there too
well good morning michelle prices are up
everywhere you know a lot of people have
roller coasters on their summer vacation
plan but we're all on the roller coaster
of rising prices
and that is not
a fun thrill ride
tatiana white's high school graduation
brought family from georgia maryland and
connecticut to daytona beach florida
did getting here cost you more than you
thought it would oh yeah but vacation
inflation has them spending more for
just about everything evelese cruz came
from hartford what was your budget where
do you think you'll end up i mean i
wanted to keep it anywhere between 2000
i'll probably be close to four by the
end of this
domestic airfare is costing flyers like
crews 34 percent more than 2019
airbnb prices are up 11 percent this
year and the average hotel room cost
nearly 171 dollars a night in may that's
40 bucks more than a year ago rental
cars have soared a stunning 70 percent
during the pandemic
there are just so many expenses that
people forget about when it comes to
travel but i do think the biggest pain
point for people right now is those car
rental prices
surging travel demand coupled with
increasing costs being passed on to
customers is stretching travel budgets
nerd wallets research finds it also is
costing more just to do things on
vacation eating out costs 7.2 percent
more than it did last year tickets for
movies theaters and concerts up nearly
six percent for leonida rivera the real
budget killer
that all too familiar pain at the pump
it's just hard pay gas
five dollars
nearly 43 percent of americans say
economic concerns are now prompting them
to reduce travel or cut their vacation
budget i was going to go to antelope
canyon i was going to do yosemite
yellowstone
we found sean sherman topping off his rv
with more than 200 of diesel work is
driving him to new york this time but
the cost of fuel put the brakes on a
family road trip i just said look we're
putting it on the back burner for now
and it broke some hearts but that's the
reality
so what can you do one be flexible in
your travel times and dates but in book
early now when it comes to travel
planning sally french from nerdwall you
saw in our story recommended flipping
how you do it book the rental car first
then the hotel and the flights and when
we're talking about rental cars think
about booking away from the airport like
at a downtown location airport locations
add a bunch of fees that can be 10 to 15
or more a day extra purely in fees tony
chris vancleave from the beaches of
virginia to the theme parks of texas
you're having a week and importantly you
got a charge card with the company's
name on it for the gas prices thank you
very much